speaking of Technology the first
artificial intelligence love song has
been created
we've got some of the lyrics here this
is by Lovelace GPT they plugged in
thousands and thousands of love poems
and song lyrics and then they came up
with a song Here Delirious ecstasy the
opening line of which has made some
headlines the line is you're my
biohazard baby
I thought huh
so it's just a kind of a strange lyric
is this just because the AI was
glitching I don't know I thought you
know with the sexual Revolution with the
widespread hookup culture with swipe
culture with skyrocketing rates of
venereal disease you're my biohazard
baby probably is an accurate summation
of a lot of
Modern Love so the AI once again rather
precise here